[Music]
man every walk
here feels like i'm walking right in
king you know how many times i had to
stop for david on walks yes
he played chappelle
like i know everybody's like oh i have a
big five-year-old no i'm telling you man
i have a gigantic five-year-old yeah i'm
saying have the lebron james the
five-year-olds he's huge
and
he but he's a gentle giant so i put him
in jiu jitsu and even within you know
the coach like come up you can go harder
man go harder so i'm like dude this is
the one place we can unleash the fury
man you're not gonna get arrested on
that so again it might be bad parenting
but i was like dude if you don't get
taken down this entire class i will get
you ice cream after every class if you
take them down when they get taken down
you get ice cream and sure enough man he
gets started getting the hang of it
starts double legging kids and this one
kid who called cry baby larry he cried
every glass
and he took double blast doubled him
random into the wall and then the tiger
looks and he's like damn am i in trouble
like trouble you can sprinkle tonight
daddy yeah i mean what are you trying to
split really whatever you want man this
was dope
and i dare you denver
you look like a transsexual juice
i
right on page
that's my name
what are you doing
chappelle lacy
i'm an aquarius
yeah i am yeah and aquarius is a pretty
they're uh i think we're introverts did
cancers have great skin i don't know i
feel like they do those are the june
second [ __ ] i feel that's what
i like what are we doing what's up dog
in my hometown denver's finest
i'm just trying to get through the show
so i can eat that snooze in the morning
be my second time at snooze stand thick
as snooze my favorite breakfast of all
time went to huckleberry coffee
this is the number one coffee shop in
denver
sour coffee yeah i don't know what
you're talking about i wish i had a
black rifle right now
that's it guys i can't breathe
you'll be all right the air's too
fit
[Music]
that's my time brother
scary dude it came my neighbor came and
helped me to bit my neighborhood to beat
no i'm not you did not bite your
neighbor bit my neighbor dude this man
charles
and and one of the best ways to keep
your online browsing activity private is
by using these glasses vpn when you use
expressvpn your internet connectivity
it's rerouted through a secure encrypted
server so you could serve the web
anonymously without anyone looking over
your shoulder look i know you probably
think
which i've never done but maybe
cats to learn more will you stop reading
it please
thank you you're such a fit stevie thank
you steven
so we just finished another fun episode
of king of the sting subscribe today to
their youtube channel uh and also go to
stevie weeby's yeah go to go to riffin
with griffin go to scissors also exactly
uh youtube.com
it's all about the team get get your
keyboard hat today and the link will be
in the description i love it and uh what
else do you got something going um you
got stuff to uh we just we love it we
love being here that's why we're here
yeah it's fun it's fun all right all
right that's the boys
oh what's up mtv i mean kyle come on in
man let me show you a little bit rundown
of uh chappelle's world setup uh i got
some i want to put some of my favorite
artists on the walls flyers and stuff of
course i have a lot
but i had to narrow it down and it was
tough okay we got we got some misfits
bad brains germs we got this cool
addicts load logo my boy toby morse h2o
storm stone roses of course some zapf
and roger jackson five two short ice
cube uh over here we got my man jimmy
rollins when i opened for him in 2019
and then my favorite rapper of all time
snoop dogg he is i and i and him slim
with the tilted brim what's my
[ __ ] name
i'm just kidding not for real though
this is tight i'm excited i'm excited
for everybody to check out the episodes
first one drops october 14th